if i can just linger in a little longer
in terms of the effects of drugs
on the positive like mind-expanding uh
components of it
um
what
have uh mind-altering drugs teach you
about the human mind sort of from a
neuroscience not even like a
biochemical
but just like the human mind is amazing
right yeah the places it can go
have like are there some insights you've
learned yeah from studying drugs about
the mind
yeah
can i start from a neurochemical
perspective first and then we'll go
larger just from a neurochemical
perspective i mean everything i know
about the brain i learned through drugs
you know because of my interest in drugs
so i learned a lot about dopamine
neurons in certain regions of the brain
about nephron neurons and
a wide range of other sort of how neural
transmission happens because of drugs
and so that's a really
valuable tool lesson for me uh but then
when we think that we
move out a bit and we think more
globally what have i learned in terms of
the mind
from drugs
i have really learned
how to be more forgiving of people
and myself
and
um
tolerant more tolerant of people and
certainly learned a lot more about
empathy as a result of
drug use
uh and like i said earlier
i'm
learning what we can be as a species and
it's quite incredible
but because of drugs
yeah there's a certain property of drugs
in different ways they take you out of
your body like uh
they help you evaluate yourself from
like a third person perspective it's
almost like you have a consciousness in
here and you get to step outside of it a
little bit
i mean that's kind of what meditation
does to all of these processes that's
what a hell of a good workout does too
it makes you evaluate yourself and that
somehow
that allows you to
um be forgiving to yourself and
forgiving to others
sort of empathize you trains that part
of your brain it's just stepping outside
of yourself not taking yourself too
seriously yeah that that process and
different drugs do that
in different ways obviously i don't know
from personal experience on some of them
but
i'm i'm now curious you know it it um
it's unfortunate that the the
hollywood and different stories we have
uh demonize certain drugs and sort of
basically
i don't know make it difficult for
people like me to explore those ideas
but then
i'm really thankful for people like you
who are pushing the science forward and
are unafraid to talk about this kind of
stuff
because i'm really fascinated with
consciousness on the engineering side i
really want to build robots that are
that have elements of intelligence
emotion even consciousness and for that
we need to understand in ourselves and
drugs is
all the different kinds of drugs if you
safely seems like an incredible tool to
understand ourselves and if we're
limiting ourselves from certain drugs
because of certain political games that
being played
um it's sad
yeah and people know this
a lot of middle to upper class people
know this the illicit drug trade
business
is a multi-million dollar industry
multi-billion dollar industry
that could not be supported by people
who are poor
and so and that and that has to be
supported by a lot of customers
and a lot of people around the world
know this
they're in the closet and in the book i
call for them to get out of the closet
so
we can start being more honest and we
can take the pressure off of those
people
who are not as privileged
you